they've been queuing in there hundreds
here for days to be tested for kovat
people are worried and with good cause
thousands have been quarantined after a
major outbreak at a meat plant and
hundreds of thousands have become the
first in Germany to face lockdown
measures for a second time residents
here are taking protection and social
distancing rules seriously but they're
frustrated even angry that more wasn't
done sooner to stop the spread of the
virus between workers of the factory
some tell us people from the area are
being ostracized you are going with a
car with Boutros law somewhere around
the country the best thing is that
people only look at you like this or
like this the worst case is that you get
stones on your car and scratches on your
car the workers are living in this
population they're like going to
supermarkets that I go to they're going
to the bath that I go to I think we
should have acted sooner this is the
vast plant in the goethe SLO area of
Northwest Germany where more than 1500
members of staff tested positive for
kovat they and their families are now in
quarantine but the fear is of the virus
getting into the community and further
afield questions are now being asked
about how coronavirus managed to spread
so quickly at this plant the state
governor is critical of the company for
not cooperating with the authorities
soon enough he had to order them to hand
over employees names but unions say the
cramped conditions many migrant workers
employed here live in also contributed
to the spread in an attempt to contain
the outbreak people are once again being
asked to mix only with their own
households or one other person bars
cinemas and gyms which only recently
opened their doors have been forced to
close again along with schools and
nurseries and today is stark warning
from public health officials that
conditions in meat processing plants
worldwide a ripe for ovid I think we
have new factories which are not
regulated and discussed until today and
also in the United States and Great
Britain and
in other countries like France we have
the same problems we have a lot of
outbreaks associated with these meat and
poultry producing factories and for the
people here the added frustration of
being told they can't travel to certain
areas bavaria ordering its hotels not to
accept people from good slow much hope
now rests with lockdown to contain the
virus despite all of its inconvenience
Michele Clifford Sky News Germany